let's take the number seven and divide
it by three and I'm going to
conceptualize dividing by three as let
me see how many groups of three I can
make out of the seven so let's imagine
let me draw seven things one two three
four five six seven so let me try to
create groups of three so I can
definitely create one group of three
right over here I can definitely create
another group of three so I'm able to
create two groups of three and then I
can't create any more full groups of
three I have essentially this thing
right over here left over so this right
over here I have this thing remaining
this right over here is my remainder
after creating as many groups of three
as I can and so when you see something
like this people will often say 7
divided by 3 well I can create two
groups of three
but it doesn't it doesn't divide evenly
or 3 doesn't divide evenly into seven I
end up with something left over I have a
left over have a remainder I have a
remainder of 1 so this is literally
saying 7 divided by 3 is 2 remainder 1
and that makes sense
2 times 3 is 6 so it doesn't get you all
the way to 7 but and then if you have
your extra remainder 6 plus that 1
remainder to get you all the way to 7
let's do another one let's imagine 15
divided by divided by 4
let me draw 15 objects 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 now let me try to
divide it into groups of 4 so let's see
that's 1 group of 4 that's another group
of 4 and then that's another group of 4
so I'm able to create 3 groups of 4 but
I can't create a fourth full group of 4
I am then left with this remainder right
over here I have a remainder of I have a
remainder right over here of 3 I have 3
left over so we could say that 15
divided by 4 is 3 remainder 3 4 goes
into 15 3 times but that only gets us to
12
four times three is 12 to get all the
way to 15 we need to use our remainder
we have to get three more so 15 divided
by four I have three left over